olá bom dia a todas ea todos
eu espero todo mundo esteja bem obrigada
por terem vindo antes de começar eu
queria fazer um convite para vocês a
gente começar a relaxante está começando
nosso dia é um horário propício para a
gente focar e conseguir concentrar nas
coisas que a gente acha mais importantes
de uma forma boa então escolhi uma foto
que eu particularmente acho bastante
positiva é aqui do nosso brasil é como
se vocês ao olharem para ela imagino que
para a maioria pelo menos seja uma
imagem relaxante então olha para ela mas
agora feche os olhos
por favor feche os olhos e imagine que
vocês estão lá imagina que vocês estão
nessa praia para paradisíaca que tá
calor que vocês pegaram uma bebida
refrescante aqui vocês mais gostam ser
tão com as pessoas que vocês gostam e
vocês estão nesse ambiente relaxante mas
como tá quente mas eles vão melhorar o
dia de vocês e entrar nessa água límpida
transparente é para se refrescar e aí
quando vocês entram favor abra os olhos
vocês se deparam na verdade com isso
não é não é agradável quebrou e isso
daqui é só uma parte do que eu tenho
para falar para vocês o que a gente vê o
que impacta os nossos olhos o que
impacta os nossos sentidos mas tem muito
mais que isso na poluição plástica o
microplastico que essa é uma das
partículas que a gente não vê tão também
na nossa comida e aí a outra é o símbolo
diz então na água que a gente bebe seja
água mineral seja a água de torneira
então no ar que a gente respira ela já
estão por todo lado e gente não é à toa
que o plástico se multiplicou da forma
como se multiplicou a gente tem ouvido
muito claro lado negativo do plástico
essa poluição que ele causa mas ele é
barato ele é flexível o que significa a
gente consegue moldar em diferentes
formatos isso torna ele versátil
eu e mais do que isso fácil de colorir
porque também de estética viverá o ser
humano né a gente gosta de coisas
agradável os olhos então comercialmente
excelente além disso ele tem mais de 14
tipos diferentes com 14 tipos diferentes
imagina a quantidade de coisa que a
gente consegue fazer com isso a gente
observa ele nosso dia-a-dia nas águas
que a gente bebe nos produtos de limpeza
que a gente usa nos remédios que a gente
toma nas embalagens em geral quando a
gente vai comprar a consumir a gente
observa na sacolinha plástica quando a
gente faz as compras a gente observa nos
canudos a gente observa em utensílios de
uso único de modo geral mais do que
esses que a gente está acostumado a
ouvir o tempo inteiro a gente tem dentro
dos carros transportes os objetos que
compõem são de plástico os pneus têm
elementos plástico e a cada momento que
eles rodam ali entram infecção com
asfalto eles estão liberando
microplastico que a gente não tá vendo
da mesma forma as nossas roupas
e quando a gente lava tão liberando os
nossos sapatos que quando a gente pisa
liberam microplastico os cosméticos e
maquiagens em geral não só embalagem tá
eu não tô falando da embalagem tô
falando da composição das coisas que a
gente usa
os fios e cabos
e os nossos do dia a dia e né
inseparáveis o tempo inteiro nossos
aparelhos eletrônicos e até para
isolamento térmico que é que no brasil a
gente não precisa tanto mas ao redor do
mundo são tão usados e eu poderia
continuar com a lista aqui só que eu
tenho um tempo né que me passaram então
a gente não pode ficar o dia inteiro
fazendo uma lista dos que a gente faz
é esse uso é representado nesse gráfico
e desde 1950 que é uma desgraça começa
até 2018 percebam como que isso sobe e
100 milhões de toneladas de plástico
produzido a gente só para dois plástico
há cerca de cem anos da forma como a
gente conhece hoje e foi intensificado
após a segunda guerra mundial a gente
pode até pensar assim ah mas a população
mundial cresceu muito então talvez
esteja proporcional a gente tô tá
aumentando à medida que cada um vai
surgindo precisa mas esse é o gráfico da
do crescimento da população mundial
percebe a diferença de curvatura aqui
também é milhões de pessoas também de
1950 2018
eu e mais do que isso percebi uma curva
o próximo gráfico mostra como que a
gente foi intensificando cada vez mais
na primeira na primeira reta que tem uma
inclinação menor ou seja um crescimento
mais lento é de 1956 a1989 a segunda de
2002 a 2014 a gente tá crescendo e
crescendo num ritmo cada vez mais forte
oi gente o tempo que esse plástico leva
na natureza lembre que ele está
produzindo plástico ah
há mais ou menos 100 anos ele chega a
levar 500 anos para se decompor na
natureza o que significa não todo tipo
tá mas todos eles mais do que cem anos e
o significa que todo o plástico
produzido ainda tá por aí
oi e a maioria deles na natureza porque
cinquenta por cento do plástico que a
gente produz é usado apenas uma vez
há 8 milhões de toneladas é a estimativa
otimista ou seja um mínimo que se estima
que vá parar de plástico todos os anos
nos oceanos
e se a gente continuar nesse ritmo até
2050 a gente vai ter em peso nos oceanos
mais plástico daqui peixes
a oitenta por cento desse plástico que
vai parar lá nos oceanos sair daqui de
terra a gente pode pensar que são os
navios que é a pesca não oitenta por
cento vendo aqui principalmente levado
pelos rios e por falar em rios apenas 10
rios estima-se que são responsáveis por
87 a noventa e cinco porcento de todo o
plástico que tem nos oceanos é uma
estimativa os dados ainda não são sem
por cento apurados que a gente ainda
precisa de muita pesquisa esses rios
estão principalmente na ásia e na áfrica
o que faz sentido por questões de falta
de saneamento básico e de população mas
não significa que nós brasileiros
podemos possamos comemorar o que as
nossas pesquisas ainda não estão
atualizadas
e no mundo a gente tem que olhar para
isso e eu acho que vocês têm percebido
essa crescente de vez em quando aparece
uma reportagem um projeto de lei mas
apesar do aspecto internacional desse
problema de parecer que o mundo tá
olhando mais para ele a gente não tem
nenhum tratado internacional que fale
sobre o plástico a gente tem alguns que
falam de temas afins alguns que a gente
tenta aplicar a gente canto direito
então senta daquele jeitinho aplicação
analógica e etc mas a gente não tem
tratados que tratam sobre isso as
corporações e as organizações civis
começam um movimento gradativo mas que
ainda não é proporcional ao tamanho do
desafio não só internacionalmente porque
a gente precisa lidar com um problema
que também é local né os efeitos são
sentidos no mundo todo mas é local a
gente tem visto acho que vocês observam
pensam de 2012 lembra os movimentos das
sacolas plásticas a tentativa de baile
dos mercados mas que a gente tem
tentativas que ainda não produzem
efeitos práticos em são paulo
e as custas foram inundadas de processos
para reverter as acções que tentavam
banir as sacolas plásticos nos mercados
aqui em vitória na região metropolitana
a mesma coisa a gente tem agora um
movimento crescente com relação aos
canudos um relação aos copos plásticos e
a gente vai observando essas coisas
pontuais que a gente ainda não consegue
enfrentar
eu ouço muito isso ah mas a gente já vai
lá para quê que eu vou banir a sacola
plástica porque basta substituir pelo
plástico que já tá lá o biodegradável
é só que gente quando a gente fala nisso
a gente fica repetindo essas palavras e
a gente precisa entender o significado
desses conceitos que que você trazem pra
gente a gente tem um termo genérico que
é o bioplástico que ele engloba na
verdade tantos plásticos de base
biológica quanto os plásticos
biodegradáveis
o e os plásticos de base biológica só
significa que eles não vem do petróleo
que a maioria do plástico vem isso não
significa que ele vai ter impacto
diferente no fim de vida dele ele pode
isso pode significar também que ele vem
de fontes como mandioca outras fontes
alimentícias que também é uma crítica
que se faz a gente vai tentar resolver
um problema tirando a comida para
transformar em plástico outra questão o
biodegradável seria aquele que se
decompõe na natureza em outros elementos
que seriam menos nocivos então por
exemplo gás carbônico água oxigênio
é só que a gente tem alguns probleminhas
aí ele não é tão rápido assim
normalmente demora de 5 a 6 anos para se
decompor quando ele é biodegradável o
que significa que jogar na natureza
também causa impactos ambientais sociais
e econômicos e ele na verdade ajuda na
compostagem então se a gente não tinha
uma destinação final adequada que leve
esse plástico para onde ele possa ser
decomposto de nada adianta mais do que
isso o conceito químico não é o mesmo
conceito jurídico as legislações às
vezes permitem que seja chamado de
biodegradável aquele plástico que tem
apenas trinta por cento de composição
biodegradável então a gente como
consumidor vai e acha que tá fazendo
nossa parte por causa dessa palavrinha
que aparece ali então a gente tem que tá
muito atento a gente tem essa quantidade
desafios e essas esses termos não podem
ser reproduzidos sem a gente prestar
atenção no que eles de fato é um
trazendo
e com isso a gente tem que pensar na
complexidade mas isso não pode nos
impedir a gente tem que buscar soluções
pensar que o problema é grande demais
não pode nos paralisar então a gente tem
desenvolvido algumas técnicas para
tentar priorizar suas ações
principalmente do ponto de vista legal
que envolve política envolve tantos
atores então como que a gente vai fazer
a gente vai dar nessa cola a gente vai
dar em copo a gente vai ficar na
discussão serviço que resolve o problema
o problema tem que ser resolvido de
várias frentes então algumas alguns
exemplos de critérios que eles pode usar
são volume das emissões então quanto de
plástico que a gente tem de fato sendo
emitido por essas fontes que a gente
está atacando a viabilidade então eles
são indispensáveis para o setor em
alguns setores produtivos se você baniu
o plástico você não consegue mais
produzir
bom então a gente tem essas alternativas
mais do que isso a gente tem
oportunidades para essas medidas a serem
tomadas ea urgência a opinião pública
deve ser levado em consideração sem
conscientização a gente não consegue os
efeitos necessários e conscientização da
sociedade dos indivíduos de modo geral
mas até das próprias empresas e governos
bom então é melhor começar por onde tem
essas essa conscientização já levantada
e alternativas para o consumidor porque
como que eu vou falar consumidor que ele
não pode usar um determinado produto se
eu não tenho uma alternativa para ele
passar o usar no lugar como que eu vou
falar por exemplo para o vendedor de
água de coco na praia que ele não pode
servir o coco com canudinho para você
beber água porque você sabe o que que
ele vai fazer ele vai abrir um pouco vai
votar no copo plástico que a pessoa tem
que sair de lá com água de coco então eu
tenho que sentar com ele eu tenho que
conversar com ele como que você pode
funcionar eu tenho que analisar essas
questões eu tenho que enfrentar isso
tenho mas não simplesmente balindo algo
que naquele momento emergiu como um
problema naquele momento eu vi a foto da
tartaruga que é muito triste então eu
quero by nilson os canudos concordo eu
tô nesse nesse time mas e aí será que em
todas as situações eu consigo talvez mas
vamos sentar e conversar para essas
soluções porque senão não pega né é o
que a gente falou das duas
bom e como eu falei tenho que repetir
são vários atores envolvidos normalmente
a gente divide em empresas sociedade e
governo e cada um deles com um papel e
cada um deles em capaz de resolver
sozinho então todos nós aqui somos
responsáveis nos nossos papéis
individuais e nos nossos papéis
profissionais seja lá quais quais sejam
os que a gente desempenho aqui eu
separei as principais funções da forma
como eu vejo as empresas na questão da
produção alternativas e novas
tecnologias e na questão da informação
informação é muito importante gente para
eu saber quanto eu produzo como eu
produzo e que tecnologias eu tenho e
muitas vezes está só nas mãos das
empresas e seu trato elas como inimigo
elas vão fechar essas informações elas
têm que estar com a gente
e a sociedade precisa estar consciente
nada ela precisa prestar atenção no
consumo e ela precisa pressionar porque
é o papel da sociedade lembra que eu
falei com os critérios é a concentração
se eu tô consciente eu consigo escolher
na hora que eu vou fazer a minha compra
se eu tô consciente eu consigo analisar
participar de uma audiência pública
enfim eu consigo conversar com uma
pessoa que sentou do meu lado no
trabalho consigo fazer tanta coisa
porque eu tenho essas informações e o
governo é claro com a regulação e
fiscalização que o papel que a gente
normalmente atribui a ele mas também com
destinação final que lembra que eu falei
algumas soluções técnicas existem mas se
a gente não tem destinação final as
coisas não funcionam e todos deles não
cada um no seu quadrado todos eles
dialogando para que a gente consiga
enfrentar a complexidade do problema
pelo que ele é
oi e aí meu convite para vocês hoje
comecei com convite termina com um
convite a gente relaxou a gente imaginou
eu acho que a gente conseguiu sentir um
pouco desse impacto que a gente tem da
complexidade que não deve ser
paralisante eu acho que a minha mensagem
tem que ser de otimismo da gente saber é
sementes né então vamos plantar essa
semente para que todo mundo saiba do que
a gente está lidando para gente sentar
entendeu um lado do outro também como
que eu vou julgar esse vendedor de água
de coco do meu exemplo se eu não
conversei com eles eu não sei o que ele
tá passando só não sei das necessidades
dele como que a gente vai entender as
dificuldades do governo se a gente não
senta com ele como que a gente vai
julgar a ação de uma determinada empresa
a gente não sabe o que tá acontecendo lá
dentro então vocês atores tem que estar
engajados tem que estar unidos para
enfrentar a complexidade do problema com
as informações que que a gente precisa
então agradeço muito pela atenção de
vocês postarem aqui hoje obrigada
[Aplausos]